[Music]
john you get a lot of calls about
narcissism and that can be a squishy
word people have a lot of opinions on
what that means
can you help us understand this yeah and
we got this article here um but
narcissism and how they
they have toxic money habits that often
go ignore or unnoticed but i think it's
important to step back and say okay
what's a narcissist that's a word that
is way overused in our culture it's just
someone i don't like it's it's we have a
lot of jerks and a lot of exhausted
people
a pathological narcissist worthy of the
diagnosis of narcissism personality
disorder and pd like that that's a those
are very different levels so a
clinically speaking uh
narcissistic personality means someone
has a very inflated sense of
self-importance a need for admiration a
lack of empathy as my friend dr cloud
henry cloud says narcissistic people
need to feel special they have an
inflated self-worth they're always
looking to feel better and they will use
you
for those means to prop them up your
pawn and their scheme think of a
dementor i'm gonna get my spirit and my
self-worth by taking from you that
happened in space jam i remember that
they sucked the powers from the
basketball
just trying to connect and relate here
john it's all right who to like kids
eating cereal face jam fans they
understand oh my gosh leave it to george
to bring this back to a lucky charms
commercial so here's the deal so we land
here with these five toxic money habits
that often go unnoticed or ignored
um in this article here from from cnbc
so it says number one
narcissists are often secretive about
their finances they keep you in the dark
they say things like let me be in charge
of the finances so you have to stress
about it and this can happen in business
too right um a narcissistic co-founder
might casually tell you the article says
since you're the creative genius i'll
just manage the boring money stuff
which is a
an incredibly subversive power
over there's a lot move
deceitfulness a lot of deception it's
about getting power right number two
there are only
generous with money in public spending
large amounts of money on others um can
be a way to get people to like them but
then they're really stingy and private
right um they might cover dinner for
colleagues or give gifts just for the
show and then their wife is like hey uh
the kids need some clothes and they're
like oh you don't figure that out on
your own right that's narcissism so a
lot of showing is happening here that's
right they're willing to do it but as
long as other people see it because the
purpose of covering that meal is not to
honor and love and serve the people who
are at the meal it's to demonstrate to
the room how great and wow john's such
an amazing guy so generous that's right
yeah number three they skimp on the
essentials here so they can be grandiose
when it comes to self-serving
unnecessary spending like buying
designer watches they can't afford
we see this a lot with um i've got six
figures of student loans but i've got
this mercedes and four rental properties
that i've bought on because i want to
have this appearance to show the world
how great i am
those intimate relationships with them
may have to quietly save money on the
site i hear that a lot
i have to create a separate world so
that i can live right whether that's
people avoiding abuse that's people
avoiding um starvation right i got
i'm pilfering money over here into a
secret account so the kids can have
clothes for school that kind of stuff
and it just doesn't even enter the mind
of a narcissist right so this is like
i'm wearing a rolex but my spouse is
complaining that the car is falling
apart and i'm like yeah that's fine i
need my rolex that's right because
fixing that car does nothing for my
image out into your reputation yeah
that's right um number four they're
hypocritical uh most narcissists
believes the rules don't apply to them
um even though they are quick to enforce
them on everybody else they may a
narcissistic partner may freely spend on
themselves and regularly join a blow the
budget and they turn around and
criticize you for you bought that shirt
and you're thinking
you just put another car
right and it's this it's it's so
hypocritical and it's often so
disproportional the response to what
actually happened well this is a lack of
integrity right there's no consistency
here right right and the final one is
they are punitive with money and we see
this a lot with narcissists they
weaponize money they use it as a way to
get things i've heard this done
um well we didn't sleep together this
week so no money for you this weekend
or
um if you don't do this or this or this
y'all we're not going on vacation right
it's a it's a
tool for punishment um they may plan
something really luxurious for your
birthday let's say the article says here
and then after an argument they're going
to refuse to pay for the expenses
leaving you on the hook because you
signed up you like go ahead and book
those tickets we're going baby and then
you you book the tickets and you get in
a fight like i'm not paying for those
tickets
and now you've got a mess right so
here's one important um caveat about
this
we are real real bad in our culture
george about quarterback um diagnosing
our friends and our loved ones ourselves
um it's the webmd effect or the google
effect you can put any number of of
things like my partner does this this
and this they may have any number of of
things right any number of diagnosis i
would say don't do that don't do that if
you are wondering if you are trapped in
a relationship with somebody who's not
safe a focus on the behaviors not the
diagnosis if someone makes you feel
unsafe if they're making you feel crazy
if they're gaslighting you all the time
if they put you in a position where you
can't pay for basic necessities
go reach out and call a professional
asap right because you're not safe leave
the diagnosis to the psychiatrist or
psychologist
let's focus on the behavior and if
you're not safe get out of that
situation asap
so as you see these symptoms
it's obviously you have to create some
boundaries and have some really hard
conversations which is not easy with a
narcissist because they're virtually
impossible they're the kings and queens
of spinning things and making you feel
crazy like you talked about with
gaslighting so what is the right way to
approach that if someone's like i think
this person's a narcissist how do i get
them out of my life or keep them at bay
you need to go talk to a professional
counselor you need to go get with a
couple of friends who you trust who
aren't going to be um yeah yeah not
those kind of friends but ones that you
can say hey here's what's happening in
my life am i is this normal
that's the most disconcerting or
heartbreaking thing when you talk to
somebody who's in a relationship with a
true
narcissist
they come to you saying hey can you help
me because i'm not good enough or hey
can you help me because i'm really
struggling
to
be a good wife or a good husband
and you listen to their story and it's
like whoa whoa whoa whoa that's not
normal right and so if you feel like
you are the worst husband ever or the
worst wife ever if you feel like you can
never do anything right or you find
yourself secretly hiding money not
because you're
lack integrity but because you're
trying to make sure the kids have
clothes go talk to a professional
counselor asap